all right so this this you have to C you
those so you have your standard form so
this hand is going to be the same on the
first variation we're going to show okay
so there's your standard form we're not
doing the standard form so tell yourself
that but the inh hand is exactly the
same on the first
variation so it's coming around the
inside it establishes the ades it on the
outside
and uses
that it's this hand that's different
okay this hand's going to do a pass so
you're going to have a disarm right
there okay I'm not really in it if you
see and now I have the
elbow more
directly his elbow is still the same you
see only I'm not
here I'm
here
[Music]
so if this hand is still the iy
hand this hand is still the iy hand then
you know this hand is the coke you
[Music]
have
there it
is
this okay
let so let's look at the what becomes
the yin hand so the yin hand cannot
start on the yin it does not start on
the Y it starts on the young you see
goes on the young so pay attention to
the pressure you see it's got to
increase okay so what I'm going to do
though is go with my body to not have it
increase so if you look my arm is here
as I come even with my shoulder there's
more pressure it's cuz my body stay here
but the arm is going forward you
understand okay so I make it it has y
but my body moved and so the pressure
stays at
neutral on the other hand I'm not going
to go like this to get
there it's a small spiral a very small
spiral and again as I have a
yield what keeps it from you not being
able to push it back like that is my
body kind of stays in place
on that side so there's a little body
you see and then this arm would already
be here you see how he's going that way
now you see that and that's where this
head would move
in so watch my body has to do this kind
of thing you see can't stay
here my body is going
to
help to keep neutral
pressure not my elbows go in and out
to not push back on a stronger person my
body is
moving so it's really soft to
him
okay try it again you have to move your
body to keep the neutral pressure your
arms don't go in and out your elbows
don't go in and
okay all right so if you if we I'll do
it I'll do it I'll do it once I'm going
to do the the whole technique slow but
you focus on my torso focus focus on
this part of my body forget what my
hands are doing and don't look at him
okay do that same side
again
so if we go back to earlier classes my
tonden field is doing its spiraling
cross
rotating okay it's not that's why this
this isn't
right everything comes from my body
now you can you can of course spiral
rotate the tonden field without any
external thing but in
Nido you're always looking
for a harmonization of the two poles so
the they both move my body moves my
tonden field moves okay I don't just do
my tanden field like in other internal
Arts would want to do that okay there's
a reason why you you do both but you
don't get the same effects from just
doing it outside do you see there's
something going on
inside so on your question of I keep
having to bend my arm here again I would
I am moving my body you see so my arm
look where my hand is in space mark a
vertical plane you see and you want
you'll hand to go about there for you to
get around the
outside so there's my arm is well move
my arm about there do you
see but it's in the in my torso moving
okay and then on your
question is well that that would be the
that would be the
external side of this
dualism which is really a monism okay
but there there's the internal side
which is yours so I don't I'm not
pulling him that would be my outer Delta
okay so um he had a pressure there's a
pressure that he had whatever it is
let's say it's X so I match X I don't
make a x + y or a x - y on the yin hand
so that pressure goes and then we're
stuck now okay so if he wants to go do
you feel that pressure it's just on that
finger
at the moment so on just that finger you
could open your grip so people could see
so just on that finger I could put him
back well of course then I could make
him go in the direction that he was
going but that's not
pulling we're
stuck for me to
pull he has to be trying to go in the
other direction do you see
but it's not me getting out of the
way because that would be me just moving
in that direction him moving in that
direction there's still him him and me
in in the adhesion there is no there's
not a him and I okay so see in other
words so if he uh if I get out of the
way you push and I get out of the way
you see his balance but if he pushes and
then stops really quick you see that's
different but if we come around and he
tries to go backwards he just increases
that I adhesion because there's more
power in it so whatever X
is I still match X but that X is a much
more energized X than the first one so
that's why it works he can't pull out
okay so I'm not pulling I'm
adhering
this is why I don't have to grip it I
don't have to cut it I here and I move
my hand here that's all I do okay on the
C part which is important for C
DOA this is me pushing
him that's not Coq just
like this isn't
iy nor is this iy me trying to get out
of the way
so what you're doing is this time will
stick and make sure that he keeps going
where I want him to go at the rate I
want him to go at the moment I want him
to go and what I'm going to
do is take that
energy into this hand and so he hits
that hand
boom and that's your Co
so
here it's just like um you're throwing
the ball into or the orange on your
bicep kind of thing only I don't move my
arm back it's kind of like that I'm
making him hit that ground
vector and he goes out so it's not
sometimes if you see my hand go just cuz
I I want to stick to him you see so when
he goes when he goes up I I get that
same the other R don't confuse that
though this is totally
different you make him hit that hand
that hand takes the energy it goes down
it bounces back out that hand and so now
you have your kazushi pattern that
spiraling rotating cross which means if
I were to stop the pattern one of those
lines of the Cross is going that way
well that means the other line is going
that way do you see they don't both go
the same
way just like in the bump
sweep okay so this hand goes that way
and then there has to be another
projecting force that
way that's what I
do okay so try it again
okay in this second one uh we're going
to take that hand
youing we're going take that coo
hand but this sound is going to be
another so it's not a lock he comes into
it you
see so just like he's coming into that
one on the last technique he's going to
come into that one so this this hand is
is kind of throwing him you see it's
kind of this is now your adhesion if you
pay attention so I go in
here once I am here then this hand comes
this
way and then he's going to hit pop a lot
you understand so do you understand you
look confused okay so I was using this
hand to bring and load him boom onto
this hand this time I'm using the first
hand but I'm not energetically using it
the same way it goes there and throws
him into the lock so this
hand has the same shape as the first one
but does not have the same energetic
value of the first one it has has the I
adhesion of the yin hand in the first
you see this Yin hand loaded the young
hand this hand now loads Boom the young
hand same shape different value okay
let's
try Okay so the the other hand came here
on the first tech R threw him in okay
this time it goes here and it keeps
going this
way again it's an adhesion so he lets go
it's not it's not that he's hold on to
me can let go he lets go it's still
going to work
okay so just note that I I'm going to
have to move my body because I move both
my body and my tund field in IO my body
moves okay down I'm there and my body my
feel
rotate then this hand is going to do
very similar thing cuz it doesn't want
to contest and it wants to find that Nel
there so you go like this with your
elbow you're going to escape out you
don't want to escape out so my body
moves see my body moves and I'm here and
this is what he
hits
hand let it go into that hand let him
hit this hand his energy HS that if you
pay attention I'll try to make this
point cuz I think it will show what I'm
doing right here nothing's
happening nothing's Happ there's I I I
have F my body the right way but there's
no
rebound watch as I increase this hand
into this
hand that's what does it okay don't come
around and
go your feet does
time okay try it
again so the obvious thing to do is to
push
pull it's it's very obvious but why is
it obvious why
why is that all I can see why is that
all I can understand why does that come
to me more why do I I believe that's all
there is because that is the structure
of the ego tripartite mind Push Pull
it's dichotomy that's how it works okay
so same thing as I'm doing the second
technique you're like I can see the
push so I want to push but even in the
first technique as you came
around I'm making him boom hit hits me
you see he bounc off me I didn't push
him
right it's exactly the same in the
second one as I come around
here I'm not going to do two
pushes this hand makes him come into it
so if you pay attention I have my x
pattern
again this hand is going to make him his
head go around this
way this hand is the X P going that way
you see as I bring him into
it there's not two hands going like
this one hand is going this way
and one hand is going that way and I
combine the
two okay and again if you watch the
projecting
hand I won't do what I do is I train
myself so as I train myself as I pop him
I stick to him so you see my hand go
away and you think that that projected
him again what I'm doing is just getting
more reps on connection
but I won't have that hand do that this
time and just here it just stays here
and you can see the direction that that
hand is going they're not on the same
path and this one's not going out
okay try again